C'est vraiment
génial. Ce jeu est sans aucun doute le
meilleur jeu mon petit poney sur Game
Boy Advance. Peut-être parce que c'est
le seul, mais surtout parce qu'il est
super. Vous contrôlez un petit poney
rose à travers une histoire et une série
de minijeux. Vous devez par exemple
habiller votre poney pour aller le
prostituer sur le trottoir de la cité
arc-en-ciel ou souffle dans une chenille
avec vos oau. Le gameplay de ce jeu est
tout à fait passionnant et vous
permettra de mon dieu, qu'est-ce que je
suis en train de faire ?
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Quand on revient au début des années 90,
c'était quand même l'âge d'or des
dessins animés. On avait encore les
restes des années 80 comme les Golds
d'Oracle, les Cités d'or, les Amator et
on avait déjà les nouveaux arrivants
comme les Dragon Ball, les Chevali
Zodiaques ou les Tortu Ninja par
exemple. Alors pour personne au milieu
de ça, c'était quand même bien
difficile. Du coup, il y a pas mal de
séries qui sont arrivées dans cette
période qui se sont cassé les dents.
Mais bon, évidemment, c'est pas le cas
de la série dont on va parler là parce
que vous connaissez tous James Bond
Junior.
Mais quoi ? Mais si, c'est ça là.
Bonjour, mon nom est Bond. James Bond
Junior. Je suis le neveu du plus célèbre
agent secret du monde. Vous savez
007. Bon, OK, ça va, j'ai compris.
Personne connaît. C'était nul. Je sais.
En fait, la série est même pas resté 3
mois à l'antenne en France avant d'être
retirée. Je vais pas la critiquer, ça
sera un peu comme tiré sur l'ambulance.
Par contre, le jeu lui, il est resté
dans les mémoires mais pas pour les
bonnes raisons. On va commencer par la
version S.
James Bond Junior sorti en même temps
sur NES et sur Super NES en 1992. On y
incarne le neveu de James Bond qui est
agent secret parce que c'est bien connu
que quand oncle est agent secret par
déduction toi tu l' aussi. Bon
allez. OK. Ouais. Bon moi je peux pas
aller par là. Je suppose qu'il faut
sauter dans le
trou. D'accord. Alors le but c'est de
trouver 5 missiles 40 minutes, ça
devrait aller je pense. James Bond
arrive à sauter comme s'il était sur la
lune. Le jeu en lui-même, c'est un jeu
de plateforme ultra classique. On se
balade en des ennemis, on ramasse des
armes dont don j'ai aucune idée de leur
utilité pour l'instant vu que j'ai
trouvé aucun bouton pour switch les
armes. Je pense qu'il y en a un mais
bon, c'est comme tous les jeunesses que
j'ai, j'ai perdu le livret. Donc voilà.
D'ailleurs, je dois quand même dire que
c'est mal foutu he parce que autant chez
Sega les boîtes étaient en plastique et
du coup on conservait le livret super
longtemps. Il était bien rangé. Autant
chez Nintendo, c'était de la merde en
carton, ça se bousiait super vite et du
coup le livret, il traîit n'importe où
jusqu'à ce qu'on le perde. Du coup, j'ai
dû chercher sur le net comme un switch
d'armes et comme tout jeu pourri. C'est
une combinaison pourrie, c'est-à-dire
select plus bas. J'arrive à la première
fusée à désamorcer. Il faut refaire en
fait le schéma qu'il y a sur le côté,
mais c'est vraiment carrément totalement
super
dur. Sérieux
quoi. Mais pourquoi ça doit être aussi
compliqué ? Sérieux ? Et puis en fait,
mais vous croyez vraiment que si les
terroristes voulaient détruire le monde
avec un missile, il s'amuseraiit à
[ __ ] une application des mineurs ou
rubicube.x pour désamorcer leur bombe ?
Ça va vous permettre de forcer les
[Musique]
fichiers. C'est pas
vrai. Ça marche. Ce jeu est
particulièrement vicieux. Le level
design est totalement anarchique. On
monte, on descend, on va à gauche, à
droite, on se mélange complètement.
Est-ce que j'ai désamorcé la seconde
bombe ou est-ce que c'était la 4e ?
Est-ce que j'avance ? Est-ce que je
recule ? [ __ ] je comprends rien quoi.
Les plateformes de saut en plus ont
l'air d'avoir été placé là de manière
mais totalement au hasard. Regardez ça.
[ __ ] je vais avancer, je veux sauter
en face mais je me coince sur le haut du
le haut du front là sur cette [ __ ] de
plateforme. Je vous parle même pas des
changements d'écran quand on va
atteindre un truc qui est hors chance.
C'est laisse tomber
l'épilepsie et il y a des passages
sérieux. C'est indescriptible. C'est
impossible de passer sans se faire
toucher. C'est il y a aucun temps
[Musique]
mort. Il a vraiment l'air d'un abruti
quand il fait
ça. Et sérieux, mais vous êtes tout le
temps en train de prendre des coups.
Passez niveau 3 en fait. Tous les
ennemis ont des balles à la tête
chercheuse, c'est magnifique. Et même
les abeilles ont des flemmes quoi. C'est
un truc de fou. Heureusement, les
développeurs, ils sont squ ils ont mis
une grosse barre de vie, ce qui vous
permet de souffrir encore plus
longtemps. Ah ben tiens, je suis sorti
de la jungle et maintenant il y a des
têtes de lit de pack qui sautent en me
balançant des œufs. des yeux de
[Musique]
pack. C'est chiant, hein ? Et vous, ça
fait que 10 secondes que vous l'écoutez.
Moi, j'ai écouté ça pendant des dizaines
de minutes et il y a cinq fusées à
désamorcer. Et si vous pensez que c'est
comme genre dans les autres jeux avec un
level 1 impossible et les autres
totalement baclés, non. Tous les niveaux
sont impossibles. Au level 2, c'est
carrément un truc de fou. Il faut
désamorcer six coffres. Chaque coffre
étant perdu à un endroit du bâtiment.
Bâtiment de merde étant blindé de cul de
sac et de portes invisibles. Me demandez
pas pourquoi elles sont visibles. J'en
ai aucune idée. Toutes les pièces du
bâtiment évidemment se ressemblent.
Chaque coffre possède quatre chiffres à
trouver. Chaque chiffre a neuf
possibilités. Alors, de 0 à 9, vous avez
neuf tentatives, ce qui nous donne un
total de 36 combinaisons possibles par
coffre multiplié par 6 coffre à
désamorcer pour un total de 216
combinaisons possibles et pour finir le
niveau en moins de 25 minutes, soit 8
combinaisons par minute en supposant que
vous soyez pas perdu dans ce bordel de
merde et que vous sachiez exactement où
aller. [ __ ] de merde
! Le pire, c'est que les combinaisons
sont jamais les mêmes. Si vous avez
trouvé trois chiffres sur quatre à une
tentative, la combinaison aura changé à
l'essai suivant. Est-ce que ce truc est
un jeu ou un outil de torture quoi ? Et
puis merde, couillon là, mais tuas tu as
des bombes sur toi. Fais le péter le
coffre. Mais sérieux, c'est si j'ai
envie de galérer comme ça sur un jeu,
autant aller acheter Mist, pas James
Zone Junior,
[Musique]
quoi. Non, pu merde. Allez, vas-y,
casse-toi, tu
m'énerves. Normalement, je suis censé me
taper la version Super NES là. J'ai Mais
c'est vraiment trop relou quoi. J'ai pas
envie. C'est bon, je préfère aller je
préfère ressortir petit poney, c'est 10
fois mieux. Allez,
[Musique]
vas-y. James Bond Junior sur Super NES
sorti la même année que la version NES.
Alors, j'ai aucune idée de si dans
l'histoire ça se passe avant ou après le
jeu sur NES, mais en tout cas,
maintenant qu'il est en couleur, je
remarque que visiblement le passage du
niveau 2 sur NES l'a fait sombrer dans
[Musique]
l'alcoolisme. Le premier niveau, c'est
un shoot zem. On pilote un hélicoptère à
la maniabilité épouvantable. J'ai
l'impression de piloter une brique. Le
niveau est long mais c'est long, c'est
interminable. C'est a absolument aucun
fun. Et le pire c'est qu'il vous suffit
mais de frôler une feuille pour exploser
votre
engin. 5. OK.
Attention une feuille.
À part ça, je tiens quand même à faire
une remarque sur le fond du
[Musique]
jeu. Je rappelle que James Junior est un
agent secret.
Niveau 2, je suis dans un temple
mailleur rempli de zouou.
Bon, c'est la vie, hein. Enfin, c'est
vraiment à partir de ce niveau qu'en
fait le vrai jeu commence, enfin les
emmerdements commencent déjà les
contrôles. Autant la gestion des sauts
n'est pas vraiment mauvaise, on n' pas
trop de difficulté à atteindre l'endroit
visé, autant les animations elles sont
vraiment pas terribles. D'ailleurs, ben
on a un bouton pied, un bouton point,
mais ils n'ont strictement aucune
utilité. Tenez, par exemple, ce niveau 2
est rempli de serpent, sauf que je ne
peux absolument pas taper au rat du sol.
Du coup, pour tuer le moindre petit
serpent, je suis obligé de leur balancer
des grenades sur la tronche ou bien de
leur jouer une fantastique musique
[Musique]
hypnotisante. D'ailleurs, à propos de la
musique du
[Musique]
jeu, pour une super nesse, c'est
vraiment nul à chier. Et encore, c'est
celle du premier niveau, la moins
mauvaise. He les autres, c'est juste des
loupes de 5
secondes. Sérieux, mais les niveaux sont
interminables. On retrouve la même tar
que dans la version NES. On monte, on
descend, on va à gauche, on va à droite,
on ramasse des trucs, on passe devant
des entrées, on sait pas s'il faut y
aller aussi. Ça va vous emmener ramasser
un pauvre item qui vous fiera 200
points. Mais des fois, on arrive à un
mur, on rentre dedans, la musique
s'arrête, on a un fondu au noir, on
croit que c'est fini et là, un sourire
se dessine sur votre visage. On croit
qu'on est libre
enfin. Mais ça recommence encore et on
continue à aller dans tous les
sens. Ce jeu, c'est un peu comme la
série Lost. Vous savez quand vous
commencez mais vous savez jamais quand
ça va
[Musique]
finir. Alors ça c'est vraiment un truc
que je déteste. Il me reste que seul
cœur d'énergie et dès que je recule pour
éviter son coup, il repope. Évidemment,
je peux pas tirer à coup ta sœur. Et
c'est pas vrai quoi. À chaque fois, je
repope au début, il y a pas de [ __ ] de
checkpoint dans ce
jeu. Allez, vas-y. Tentative désespérée.
Ça sert à rien mais bon c'est la classe.
OK. Briefing mission ou là les gars
parlez pas tous en même temps. Oh j'ai
inventé une
On enchaîne ensuite par d'autres niveaux
selon le même principe. Un niveau en
véhicule puis un niveau à pied. En fait
c'est paradoxal parce que les niveaux en
véhicule c'est peut-être la partie la
moins mauvaise du jeu. Notamment dans la
mission 5 où on dirait que James Bond
pilote un chasseur dans la stratosphère
de Jupiter et qui pour le coup ressemble
carrément à un air taille.
Niveau 4 maintenant on est dans les
égouts et comme dans tous les égouts
dans les jeux vidéos, il y a des mars
vertes de plutonium qui traînent
partout. Les fonctionnaires de la
municipalité, ils ont installé des pics
pour embrocher les gens. Vous pouvez
leur aplatir la gueule sur les murs.
Super. On se fait renverser par des
vagues dans des flagues de 30 cm de
haut. Génial. D'ailleurs, on commence à
ce niveau à ramasser des items, mais
c'est complètement barré. Ça ressemble à
rien. Du coup, on est souvent bloqué
parce qu'on ose plus avancer alors qu'en
fait on pourrait parce qu'on a le bon
item. Et ça, c'est quoi là pour vous ?
C'est un masque à gaz. Et il apparaît
même pas sur sa gueule. [ __ ]
qu'est-ce que c'est ça pour vous ? C'est
une grenade qui permet de congeler l'eau
pour la rendre solide. [ __ ] mais
comment je suis censé vider ça moi ? Bon
alors ouais ok. Normalement ma chien là
vous décrit les objets dans le briefing.
Mais sérieusement, moi quand j'avais 10
ans, je les ai jamais les briefings. Et
puis même aussi, c'est c'est genre tu
sais et James, j'ai inventé des supers
objets qui te seront très utiles dans ta
mission mais en fait tu vois comme je
t'aime pas, plutôt que te les donner
directement, je les ai caché dans des
endroits improbables où tu vas en chien
max pour les récupérer. Voilà. Allez,
amuse-toi bien ma couille.
Le poste du niveau, il est juste
catastrophique. Ça se passe de
[Musique]
commentaires. Après ça, on continue les
niveaux. C'est tellement la même chose
qu'on a l'impression que le temps passe
au ralenti comme quand vous regardez un
épisode d'IC.
Le téléphone
sonne pour
décrocher ou je décroche. On passe d'une
connerie à l'autre. Je commence à
bouillir de rage là. Je vais même pas
vous parler du level 4. Je vais juste
vous montrer votre récompense après
avoir transpiré pendant des heures sur
cet infam atrocité. Alors oui, je sais,
il y a pire. Mais vo quand tu en as chié
pendant des jours pour tester ce truc
mais voilà ce que tu te tapes à la fin
quoi.
[Musique]
Tu vas me le payer James Bond Junior ?
Pas de problème garde la monnaie.
Voilà une blague carambar un écran de fa
pourri. Allez, un support et un lit.
Ah. Bonjour monsieur Grenier.
Je suis là, je suis là.
Bonjour
monsieur, vous êtes qui ? Devine, je
suis le père Noël.
Vous tombez bien, père Noël parce que
justement moi figurez-vous qu'à Noël,
j'avais commandé. Non, mais je suis pas
le père Noël.
[Musique]
De toute manière, ça change rien parce
que tu vas mourir ici. Mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ? parce que c'est écrit dans le
scénario. En tout cas, tu ne sortiras
jamais d'ici. À moins que tu défais tes
liens à l'aide de ce coteau et le laisse
plusamment traîner sur la table et que
tu désamorces cette bombe à l'aide de ce
manuel. Le français
pas. Si tu réussis pour
ça, je n'aurai aucune
chance. Aucune chance.
Sal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Allez, quel âge mon cerveau ? 73 ans.
[ __ ] mais c'est quoi ce jeu pourri là
? Ah merde, [ __ ]
là-bas.
[ __ ] non, [ __ ] 15
secondes. Oh le manuel.
Bonjour et félicitations pour l'achat de
votre bombe turbo F3000. Une fois sorti
de l'emballage, veillez vérifier que
j'ai pas de temps.
[ __ ] presque 5 secondes.
[ __ ] tu pu
merde mon plat était parfait. Tu me le
peras gadget euh grenier à feuille.
[Musique]